husband has been prescribed statins after his procedure with two heart stints
which side effects should he look out for while taking statins?
well really you want to look out for all your any possible side effects with taking any drugs
and any culture affects between drugs as well so I always recommend people go to drugs.com
and you can search your drug with your drug in and they have a free search for side effects
I think that's a pretty good website you can google it as well to look for the side effects and
you should maybe print out the different possible side effects of the drug that you have to take
and then be looking out for it their side effects because they have been proven to occur in people
taking the medication so when drugs get approved they go through different studies
and in one of the phases of the study they have to have x amount of people out the drug and they
have to record any side effects that the person has had that's why when you watch these drug commercials
and it might say even early death because somebody died on the study and it could have been
paused from the drug maybe they had other core of entities but it's just they have to list it
and there's usually a lot of them that's why they have some you know person that was traded
auctioneer school to read that at the end of the commercial so it is something that you should look
up and we become basically immune to all the possible issues of different medications
and you know I think I don't know if I shared last week or not but it's something as a practitioner
that I have failed sometimes because I I don't take drugs so I forget to ask people you know you know
to make that a pertinent question of oh you have this symptom what drug are you taking if you
looked up the side effects of that drug I certainly don't have all the side effects of different
drugs but memorize the order I attend to so I think it's easy anything you can look up you should
just do that I'd go to drugs.com and look those up I don't know what particular ones that you should
be looking for you should use to look for anything that you possibly have also if you are taking
other medication they true you look those things up to and if you can buy daily drug interactions because
I think drugs.com they also have drug inter interaction piece of that search that I would search
and look for that as well